what's going on guys Eddie truck gordon
UFC season 19 ultimate fighter champion
current pfl fighter jonathan Cepeda 17
and 2 15 knockouts as a professional
boxer three-time Golden Gloves champion
everything in the amateur is I won and
I'm here for you be quite honest men I
was not expecting much from this fight
you figured Logan Paul has a zero pro
fights zero boxing matches case I had a
little more experience he had one fight
coming in so I'll expecting sloppy
haymakers just just swinging for the
fences no ring generalship that's how
they're gonna be super boring or super
entertaining because boxers nowadays
like big box so the art of boxing is hit
and not get hit like a Floyd Mayweather
so everybody hates that because they're
running around and when you don't know
how to box is literally two bulls just
charging each other before I start a
fight I thought case I was gonna win
just agree had more fight experience
when I found out that Logan hasn't
fought before in front of people that
way like I said because it's so
different it is extremely different with
the adrenaline I gave the edge to ksi
because he went through that experience
right I tell you what man I was
impressed with with a lot with this
fight what I saw blew me away because I
saw somebody I was comfortable in the
ring I saw somebody I was that was
living off the moment like a veteran so
that to me alone was all pretty awesome
first case eyes movement his head
movement was really good at kind of mind
like a Mike Tyson you know slip and left
slip and right I think if they would
actually threw a few left hooks because
they were just throwing like the one
tooth or the haymakers I believe that
Logan could have stopped KS I would have
been more training and just more
executing more technique with left hook
I'm a left hooker so that's my favorite
punch out of 15 knockouts 13 of my
knockout was all of them by left hook
Logan had a real good job so if you
would have used it a little bit more to
double it up throw the cross and follow
up with the left hook I believe it could
have stopped my opinion Logan won the
fight towards the end of the fight I
think case I start to turn it on a
little bit more maybe maybe his
condition it was a little bit better
since he had that that fight our
previous fight and Logan Paul has a
bigger frame they can tie so no doubt in
my mind if you had to
whoa wait that's gonna affect his cardio
is gonna affect how much punches he
could absorb and that's why I feel I
have to fight we're all living longer
case I had a great opportunity to finish
that fight because when you lose weight
when you cut weight the actual fluid
around your brain gets depleted as well
I agree with the draw I can see where
they came up with the drawer Logan edged
it out by winning a couple early rounds
I feel it was a one or two more rounds
that case I had a chance to fight I'm
gonna stop they stopped their reaction
at the end of the fight they both look
pissed I definitely I don't think it was
rigged I would never want to draw I
can't sleep with a draw Jake and Desi it
was just basically a slaughterhouse
Jake had extreme composure if he just
would have came around with the left
foot I think he would have put him down
he looked like a natural he looked like
he wanted to be nice he look like he
trained for the fight he was the
aggressor he was the predator I feel
like that he was the prey Reggie come
train with me
in conclusion I think that was awesome
man ksi Jake Logan all you guys laid it
out on the line if you want to get
another fight come holla at me come
holler at my boy they're gonna get you
guys right we're here for you
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part